mein größter traum überhaupt überleben
das ist ein bauernhof zu haben im moment
honig in der wohnung mitten in der stadt
und ohne eigenen garten das heißt ich
nutze für meine selbstversorger projekte
im moment die kunststücke von anderen
leuten die so nett sind mir zu erlauben
dass ich der beete anlegen wenn ich im
gegenzug den rasen mähen aber je länger
ich das mache desto mehr merke ich wie
viel schöner dass selbstversorger leben
mit einem eigenen garten direkt im haus
wäre die frau so dringend einen eigenen
bauernhof mit festen zeiten wo keine
ziege in diesen blöden elektronischen
bleibt und deswegen haben mein damaliger
freund und ich uns vor drei jahren auf
hof suche begeben und dann ziemlich
schnell gemerkt dass das gar nicht so
einfach ist wie wir dachten sich die
nummer 5 1263
wir haben jetzt ein abend den hof
abgesagt weil es einfach letztendlich zu
teuer wir wollten gut angebunden sein
für die arbeit und vor allem für die
schule vor meinem sohn und ein großes
grundstück seit es haben und bitte bitte
bitte nicht zu teuer aber gleichzeitig
vielleicht auch ein bisschen schön ja
versucht mal sowas zu finden wären
ziemlich schnell gemerkt dass das eben
das ist was jeder sucht und dass wir
absolut keine chance haben so was hier
in unserer umgebung zu finden es gab
mehrere hilfe die wir angeschaut haben
wo wir kurz davor waren auch teilweise
die zu kaufen in die ich mich hals über
kopf verliebt habe und das hat so
wehgetan den hof dann letztendlich nicht
zu bekommen und dann habe ich mich vor
ungefähr anderthalb jahren knapp von
meinem damaligen freund getrennt aus
anderen gründen
aber ich wusste in diesem moment dass
meinhof traum damit geplatzt ist weil
wie soll ich das alleine alles
hinkriegen eine trennung ist nicht schön
und ich rede auch eigentlich gar nicht
über so was auf meinem kanal aber ich
glaube dass das um diese geschichte von
diesem hof kauf zu verstehen schon
wichtig ist dass wir das wüssten wir
waren neun jahre zusammen das heißt wir
sind zusammen gekommen als wir noch bei
seinen eltern gewohnt haben wir sind
zusammen in unsere erste eigene wohnung
gezogen und ich war noch nie erwachsen
alleine bis zu dem punkt und ich weiß
noch wie ich als kind einmal weint
aufgewachte nachts und meine mutter kam
und hat gefragt was denn los und ich
hatte einen alptraum das ich ausziehen
müsste und dass ich gar nicht weiß wie
man überhaupt strom anmelden und genauso
habe ich mich in dem moment gefühlt als
ich dann in also ausgezogen bin aus
unserer gemeinsamen wohnung in eine
eigene wohnung und habe ich meine mama
angerufen total verzweifelt manchmal
mehr strom anmeldet
dann war die vorstellung wenn doch schon
irgendwie schwierig war für mich aber
die vorstellung einen eigenen bauernhof
alleine zu kaufen war einfach völlig vom
tisch und dann kommt ihr ins spiel weil
ich hatte mal in dem video erwähnt dass
wir einen hof suchen und daraufhin kam
so vielen liebe nachrichten von leuten
aber leider ganz oft von höfen die viel
zu weit weg sind in regionen wo wir gar
nicht hin ziehen konnten so dass da kein
hof dabei war der für uns in frage kam
aber vereinzelt kamen wegen dieses
videos immer noch mails und die haben
mich ehrlich gesagt total traurig
gemacht weil ich die gelesen habe und
gedacht hab ja ich will ich würde so
gerne aber ich kann nicht ich bin kann
es immer zu null grad ich hatte
irgendwie das gefühl ich habe nicht nur
meine familie verloren sondern auch mein
lebenstraum und dann kam eine mail von
marina
dank immerhin noch mal
maria hatte sich einen hof angeschaut
hier in der gegend
und den fand sie total schön aber der
war für sie und ihre familie zu groß und
da hat sie an mich gedacht und gedacht
sie erzählt mir mal davon und ich weiß
nicht warum aber das klang irgendwie so
schön was sie von dem hof erzählt hat
dass ich einfach hingefahren bin um den
anzuschauen auch wenn das irgendwie sich
irgendwie absurd angeführt hat aber
dieser ort hat mich so umgehauen das war
irgendwie da schon klar bei dieser
ersten besichtigung dass ich das jetzt
nicht einfach ignorieren kann dazu kam
dass der hof und wirklich im vergleich
zu allen anderen höfen die wir
angeschaut haben super günstig war und
einfach superschön nicht schick nicht
riesengroß aber ich wollte auch gar
nicht mehr so einen großen hof weil die
vorstellung da dann alleine zu sitzen
und verantwortlich zu sein für wir haben
vor einen hof mit 30 hektar angeschaut
stellt euch mal vor euch sitzt da
alleine mit meinem sohn und muss
irgendwie 30 hektar bewirtschaften das
heißt ich fand das eigentlich gar nicht
schlecht dass der hof nicht so viel land
hatte und vor allem hatte einfach super
viel charme in großen gemüsegarten mit
alten obstbäumen beete gibt's auch schon
es gebären streich an den hühnerstall
nussbäume ist es einfach ja es ist
einfach super super show und dann habe
ich einfach entschieden dass ich jetzt
alleine machen es gab dann eine
bieterrunde weil es natürlich viele
interessenten gab
[Gelächter]
er zwar recht
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
[Musik]
das hat sich so nach lücks zahl an
gefühlt auch wenn symbolische zahl ist
aber
wer so lange jetzt gesucht nachdem also
wirklich jahre
bis 20
ja und dann habe ich da alleine gesessen
und das unterschrieben ich sage euch was
strom an es ist gar nicht so schwer und
wenn man ganztag will dann kann man auch
alleine machen sich aber eben schon
gesagt dass ich eigentlich nicht so über
beziehungs sachen auf einem kanal rede
weil ich damit in der vergangenheit
nicht so gute erfahrung gemacht habe
und ja aber ich glaube es ist schön für
euch zu hören dass ich seit einiger zeit
schon einen neuen freund habe und der
ist genauso begeistert von dem bauernhof
wie ich und deswegen bin ich mit diesem
abenteuer vielleicht doch kann ich so
allein wie ich dachte ein nachteil hat
das ganze ich muss noch anderthalb jahre
warten bis ich auf den hof einziehen
kann weil wir zwar jetzt schon den
kaufvertrag unterschrieben haben ich
stehe schon im grundbuch aber die leute
ziehen erst in anderthalb jahren aus
wenn sie ihr haus gebaut haben in dass
sie umziehen wollen und deswegen muss
ich mich jetzt noch ganz gedulden ich
kann jetzt schon bäume pflanzen und
solar auf die dächer packen und alles
mögliche umbauen aber eben noch nicht
ein der selbst schwer sich zu gedulden
am liebsten würde ich sofort einen teams
ja klar ich werde bestimmt irgendwann
demnächst mal eine hochtour für euch
film im moment wunder halt noch andere
leute ich weiß nicht wie viel ich da
jetzt schon zeigen kann aber das kommt
natürlich
deswegen abonniert gerne den kanal wenn
ihr bei dem abenteuer mit dabei sein
wollt und ansonsten verlinkt ich euch da
trieben ein video das euch auch
interessieren könnte und wir sehen uns
nächsten samstag wieder im zehn für eine
rettung hat gute tipps